I hope you had a good Thanksgiving I
hope hope you had a good holiday because
well you know it was it was great I went
to my mother's house we all enjoyed the
emotional stuffing that were you eating
and you're like mom I want to talk about
you know what forget it just we're good
there's no fixing it so every sentence
ends there's no fixing it yeah well
that's that's the theme of our
Thanksgiving yeah this is what we have
to deal with there's no fixing it we did
the best we could eat eat and await the
grave it was okay where'd you go we're
hung around here
that was it that was it the studio yeah
in the studio Wow exciting just set up a
table right there right there under the
moon I ate alone I understand you went
on vacation recently please tell me that
was fun you know I do what I can
I did go on vacation I went you know
there's it's weird I don't know if
you've tried to go on vacation like I
don't know where you go but I mentioned
it to some people I want to go on
vacation and there are these people out
there that say you got to go to Cuba and
there's a moment like really do I have
to go to Cuba oh yeah before it turns
before it turns capitalistic again you
got to go it's gonna be great
and I'm like what to enjoy the charm of
a failed communist dictatorship
miserable and smoke a cigar anywhere I
don't have to go to the place where
they're made so you didn't go to Cuba mo
I went to Kauai in Hawaii they're just
traveling excited because I know no one
actually lives there you just went there
right there's three people that live
there that's the weird thing is that you
when you want to go to Kauai people are
like it's great there's nothing there
there's nothing there and then you get
there you're like there for three it
sounds great it initially there's
nothing there and then three days into
your vacation you're like there's
nothing here
we've done everything there is to do
there's nothing what are we gonna do
even the beauty gets tedious I mean
every day you go out you watch the
sunset because it's like it's amazing
and by day three they're like there yeah
it's like I I saw it like that's like
what is God hackie can he mix it up a
little bit no gravity for a few seconds
that'd be interesting sunset and also
there's roosters every word you see it's
ridiculous
all right look why are there roosters
everywhere look I don't know history the
their protective history they're like
they're like the islands bird and
they're protected no what it is is that
there was nothing no Andy no my
understanding is there's nothing on
Kauai all right and there and there
never was anything so ships would go
there and just leave crap you know what
they left they left pigs they left
chickens and because there was no
predators the pigs and chickens just
took over the place so I'm not making
this up there's literally thousands of
roosters like big roosters like the kind
of roosters when you see them you're
like holy Sh yeah there's a rooster you
know the kind you only see like twice in
a lifetime big hey I'm a rooster you
know twice I've never seen a rooster
that was like you know that's a big
rooster like that what do you mean we
have you seen only faulty roosters look
at you they're all very weird you
described a very tall rooster that's
where the word cocky comes from isn't it
all right look here's the weird thing is
like initially you're like oh my god
why are they all here and then you kind
of acclimate to the roosters and then
about three days then you realize none
of these roosters know what time it is
you know like like all day long
they're thinking like is this what
freedom does yeah I don't want for the
man
I just woke up deal with it
they're calling you on the phone